all right in this video we're going to
talk about germs that will not die
okay and I'm talking about microbes that
have antibiotic resistance there they
resist antibiotics it is becoming a huge
problem these microbes are bacterial
superbugs and they have the ability to
outsmart drugs they actually can share
their genetic code or a genetic file of
code with their buddies and their
friends so they too can be resistant
against antibiotics some even have the
ability to eat the antibiotics that are
supposed to kill them so these microbes
are mutating at a very fast rate so what
happens is these microbes are becoming
stronger and stronger and almost
impossible to kill and it's crazy 25,000
people a year die from these superbugs
that's a lot of people 266 million
prescriptions given to Americans for
antibiotics every single year I mean
there's only 300 million people in the
US and 266 million of them are given
prescriptions that's a lot of people 80
percent of all the antibiotics sold in
the world are for animals they put them
in animal feeds okay then you eat the
animals it's a huge problem so I want to
give you some solutions and things to do
so number one try to do everything you
can before you get an antibiotic don't
run to get an antibiotic like I did I
remember growing up I had an infection
with my tonsils and my throat every
single year and I had so many
antibiotics okay if you have a history
of sore throats watch the link down
below it's a great technique and a great
video to help you but there are some
real simple things you can do that are
very inexpensive that are very safe
there are natural herbal antibiotics
without any side effects they kill the
pathogenic bacteria but they don't do
anything to your own friendly bacteria
okay this is the list
rosemary mer time clove
oregano garlic tea tree oil ginger
goldenseal grapefruit seed extract these
are completely without side effects and
they make the environment so these
microbes cannot exist and lastly I put
some links down below to validate the
science behind these so you can check
that out too thanks for watching
so I suppose you're wondering how the
heck can I put out so much content to
videos every single day I'm about to
reveal how I do it okay let me show you
come on up here hey how you doing
it's my twin brother I actually can get
twice as much work done okay man over to
you I'm gonna take I'm gonna take a nap
well thank you very much all right guys
I I hope you're ready for some great
content today because we're gonna get
right into it all right